y aquí tenemos dos sustancias diferentes
supongamos que las dos se encuentran en
estado líquido probablemente ya
reconocieron esta sustancia cada
molécula tiene un átomo de oxígeno y dos
átomos de hidrógeno esto es agua agua y
he dibujado los puentes de hidrógeno
ahora esta sustancia al menos por ahora
puede ser menos familiar para ustedes
pero miren aquí tenemos un grupo h
entonces si tenemos una cadena de
carbonos esto nos dice que es un alcohol
pero qué tipo de alcohol es bueno como
solo tenemos 2 carbonos este es el
alcohol etílico o también llamado etanol
lo escribiré etanol
este es el constituyente principal en el
alcohol que las personas toman y también
es un aditivo que se usa en la gasolina
de los coches pero lo que quiero que
veamos es que si suponemos que las dos
sustancias se encuentran en estado
líquido por ejemplo imaginemos que las
en una taza y nos encontramos al nivel
del mar es decir a condiciones de
presión estándar qué sustancias se
evaporará más fácil cuál de las dos
tendrá más moléculas que se
transformarán en vapor más fácilmente
bueno a primera vista podemos ver que
las dos sustancias forman puentes de
hidrógeno aquí tenemos un puente de
hidrógeno entre la terminal parcial
negativa y la terminal parcial positiva
y por acá también tenemos un puente de
hidrógeno entre las terminales parciales
negativas y las terminales parciales
positivas otra cosa que podemos observar
es que en el etanol tenemos menos
puentes de hidrógeno de los que tenemos
en el agua en el etanol
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno pero también
es más electro negativo que el carbono
aunque éste es más electro negativo que
el hidrógeno así que aquí tenemos un
desequilibrio mientras que por acá en
estos carbonos tenemos
más átomos entre los que se distribuye
la carga parcial puede ser una carga
parcial muy débil distribuida entre los
carbonos pero tenemos una carga parcial
muy fuerte en el hidrógeno aunque no es
tan fuerte como la que tenemos acá
porque aquí tenemos una molécula más
larga para distribuirla especialmente
alrededor de este carbono que ayuda a
disipar la carga entonces aquí tenemos
cargas parciales más débiles y se
encuentran en pocos lugares porque
tenemos menos puentes de hidrógeno en el
etanol de los que tenemos en el agua lo
escribiré tenemos menos puentes de
hidrógeno
- puentes de hidrógeno y como ya dijimos
en el estado líquido y también en el
estado sólido los puentes de hidrógeno
hacen que todo esto se mantenga unido
eso es lo que permite que el agua fluya
y lo mismo ocurre con el etanol entonces
si tenemos menos puentes de hidrógeno
porque tenemos más átomos de hidrógeno
por molécula se necesita menos energía
para que estas moléculas se puedan
liberar pero antes de hablar de eso y de
que estas moléculas se convierten en
vapores es decir que cambian al estado
gaseoso pensemos en cómo ocurre verá
cuando hablamos de la temperatura de un
sistema en realidad estamos hablando de
la energía cinética promedio cada
molécula recuerden las moléculas se
están moviendo por ejemplo supongamos
que esta molécula tiene más energía
cinética que ésta y todas se mueven en
diferentes direcciones
entonces supongamos que esta molécula
tiene mucha energía cinética fue
golpeada en el punto exacto y eso es
suficiente para que estos puentes de
hidrógeno y la presión del aire que
tenemos arriba recuerden esto no ocurre
en el vacío arriba tenemos moléculas de
aire dibujaré algunas moléculas
generales pueden ser diferentes cosas
como nitrógeno dióxido de carbono
etcétera entonces también existe una
presión por parte de estas moléculas
pero si esta molécula en particular
tiene la energía cinética suficiente
para sobrepasar los puentes de hidrógeno
y la presión de las moléculas de arriba
entonces podrá vaporizarse y pasar al
estado gaseoso y lo mismo puede ocurrir
de este lado supongamos que esta es la
molécula que tiene mucha energía
cinética así que podrá liberarse y pasar
al estado gaseoso los puentes de
hidrógeno se romperán y esta molécula se
irá muy lejos de las otras moléculas de
así que ya no se podrán formar los
puentes de hidrógeno y bueno lo mismo
ocurre por acá una vez que pase al
estado gaseoso estará muy lejos de las
otras moléculas de agua y no se podrán
formar los puentes de hidrógeno pero
debido a que aquí hay más puentes de
hidrógeno por romper que acá imagínense
que en promedio aquí necesitamos más
calor para vaporizar todo esto del que
necesitamos para vaporizar todo esto y
el término para definir que tanto calor
necesitamos para vaporizar una cierta
sustancia se conoce como calor de
vaporización calor de vaporización
entonces el calor de vaporización es
mayor para el agua que para el etanol
déjenme les digo los valores encontré
algunos valores que cambian un poco
dependiendo de la fuente que consultemos
yo encontré que el valor de vaporización
del agua es de dos mil doscientos
sesenta
por grant o en lugar de usar jules
porque recuerden que los giles es una
unidad de energía en lugar de jules
podemos verlo en calorías esto es igual
a 541 calorías por gramo y bueno el
calor de vaporización para el etanol es
un poco menor el calor de vaporización
del etanol y esto corresponde al agua
agua y para el etanol de acuerdo a lo
que encontré el calor de vaporización
del etanol es de 841 jules por gramo o
si lo prefieren esto equivale a 201
calorías por gramo
eso significa que necesitaremos
aproximadamente 200 son calorías para
evaporar completamente un gramo de
etanol a temperatura estándar claro
manteniendo la temperatura constante
aquí lo importante es que se necesita
menos energía para vaporizar el etanol
hagan el experimento
tomen dos vasos iguales un vaso llenen
lo con agua y el otro con etanol pueden
poner una lámpara caliente sobre ellos o
simplemente déjenlos afuera para que
experimenten las mismas condiciones
atmosféricas y observen cuánto tiempo
más tarda el agua en evaporarse después
de que se haya evaporado el etanol y
bueno una idea similar es el punto de
ebullición seguramente todos hemos
puesto a hervir algo el punto de
ebullición es el punto en el que la
presión de vapor de una sustancia se
iguala e incluso empieza a sobrepasar la
presión atmosférica por ejemplo en este
caso el agua empieza a hervir a una
temperatura mayor que el etanol el punto
de ebullición del agua esté exactamente
100 grados celsius este fue un dato muy
importante para establecer la escala
celsius entonces para el agua es de 100
grados celsius mientras que el punto de
ebullición del etanol esté
aproximadamente
78 grados celsius hierve a una
temperatura más baja porque hay menos
fuentes de hidrógeno que romper